نعود الى ازمه الطاقه في العالم فقد تتحكم
انتظار ايام الاخرى للتوافق على اليه
لتحديد سقف لاسعار الغاز بالجمله فهل
ستكون هذه المهلكه كافيه لدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي لتجاوز خلافاتها المفوضيه
الاوروبيه كانت قد اقترحت في البدايه
تشغيل اليه لتحديد السقف تلقائيا بمجرد
تجاوز الاسعار
275 يورو للمقاوات ساعه لمده اسبوعين
متتاليين بشرطين ان تكون اعلى بما لا يقل
عن 58 يورو من متوسطه السعر المرجعيه
العالمي للغاز الطبيعي المساله في المقابل
طالبات عده دول متحفظه على اي تدخل وبينها
المانيا وهولندا والنمسا بوضع محاذير
بالغه الشده لمنع اي سقف قد يتم تحديده من
تهديد امدادات الغازي لاوروبا هذا وكانت
دول عده خصوصا اليونان وايطاليا جيكا
اقترحت خفض السقف الى 160 يورو للميجا وات
ساعه لكنها دول اخرى رفضت المقترح وسعت
براج الى جعل السقف عندئتين 220 يورو
للميجاوات ساعه يذكر ان اسعار الطاقه
الاستهلاكيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي ارتفعت
بما يقرب من
35% في نوفمبر مقارنه بالشهر نفسه من
العاني الماضي
وسطها الخلافات بشكل تحديد سعر سقفي اسعار
الغاز والخشيه المستمره من شتاء قاس قامت
الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي بخطوات مخزوني
الطاقه في منتصف سبتمبر بلغت احتياطات هذه
البلدان ثمانيه واربعين في المئه وهو
مستوى يكفي لاشهر عده من الاستهلاك في حين
تجاوزت نسبه التخزين في عدد من الدول
الاوروبيه نسبه 80% واقتربت من 90 اه كما
هو الحال بالنسبه لفرنسا وايطاليا
والمانيا وبولندا والدنمارك وتشيك
واسبانيا والسويد وتبقى بعض دول اوروبا
الشرقيه بعيده عن هذا الهدف مثل لاتفيه
التي بلغت 65% فقط وكذلك الوضع في النمسا
وفي المجر وفقا دراسات فان الخيار الوحيد
امام الدول الاوروبيه لتجاوز الاعتماد على
الغاز روسي هو خفض الاستهلاك الاوروبي
بنسبه تتراوحو ما بين 10 و15 في المئه اما
المانيا فسيكون عليها خفض استهلاك الغاز
بنسبه 20% خلال الاشهر السته المقبله
لتجاوز هذه لتجاوز هذه الازمه لم يكون
تخزين الدول الاوروبيه للغاز بالمهمه
السهله بل كلف ميزانيه الحكومات الاوروبيه
سبعين مليار دولار مقارنه مع ثني 10 او
فقدها اوروبا لتخزين الغاز خلال العام
الماضي حول هذا الملف ارحب بضيفي من
بروكسل السيد ماركو جيولي وهو خبير سياسات
الطاقه في كليه بروكسل للحكم والمستشار
السابق للسياسات الطاقه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي سيد ماركو لنبدا بمساله امكانيه
الوصول الى اتفاق بين دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي فيما يتعلق بتحديد سقف لاسعار
الغاز هل هذا وارد بعد هذه المغله
والله
المقاربه العامه الان تم الاتفاق عليها
ونقطه الخلاف المتبقيه هي مستوى او
السقف اذا هناك سياسه لاحتواء الاسعار
وايضا امن الطاقات
وتحت مستوى معين قد نخاطر بامن الطاقه
بالنسبه الى المواقف لا تزال متباعده ولكن
على الاقل يمكن التوصل الى تنازلات
الرمزيه حل وسط رمزي بنسبه الى مستويات
ليس بالضروره ان تكون مهمه ولكن طبعا هناك
الكثير من الدراما السياسيه المرتبطه
بعمليه تحديد السقف السقف الاسعار
وبالتالي يجب على الدول الاوروبيه ان تتفق
على تحديد سعر كيف هل هذا الاجراء سيد سيد
ماركو يتعلق فقط بالغاز الروسي او بكل
الغاز المنقول الى اوروبا عن طريق
الانابيب
السعر يرتبط
بالغاز او معدل السعر الذي يصل فيه الغاز
الى اوروبا وهذا تحدث فيه عن العقود بعيده
الامد الاتيه من روسيا او الغاز الروسيه
في هذه الحاله ولكن ايضا في الوقت نفسه
نتحدث عن الغاز الموجود في الاسواق الان
وبالتالي نتحدث عن تحديث السفلي
الغاز المستورد
شكرا لك من بروكسل ماركو جيولي خبير
سياسات الطاقه في كليه بروكسل الحكم
والمستشار السابق لسياسات الطاقه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي